welcome to this video kitsune Gowri
kitsune gory from the US ok I play dumb
the g6 type of opening was c5 let's see
what we get very early Quincy to chop
just prefer benoni probably try to show
that well yeah quite an unconventional
way to place a place of pieces don't
really think this can be too great but
ok it's so it's fairly solid okay so
obviously yeah mm-hmm do I'm can I just
give a giveaway b7 on should I should I
protected ya wanna play night here
okay come on I mean really taking him
again Quincy to queen bee three okay he
doesn't take i'm not i looked entirely
sure that he he couldn't okay but now i
will try to prepare b5 the interesting
would be night nie Dage form try to to
mess up my structure the bishop on a5 is
slightly exposed doesn't have anywhere
to to retreat
we are playing for b5
yeah don't know g4 yeah well I cannot I
cannot spend time on g4 stuff I mean
thinking about about this if this is
really a really good then I'm a trouble
okay so
you know I thought I can go to your
phone if he goes g58 a1c form okay well
this I didn't really think of as
critical at all
which does not necessarily mean that I'm
am I'm right we're thinking of that but
this just looked fine to me ok the
question is I didn't know it's no
question I need to get I need to be
quick rock is the right move I'm pretty
sure it moves the rock somewhere I mean
somewhere not on the a file i might play
Queen 85 and if he takes I also
threatened Queen a 185 yes this i was i
was expecting but if i take Queen takes
em yeah this is a very shaky position
queen bee 60s got time for III
hmm come on in there's certainly a way
to refute this I mean and I mean
completely refuted not only having a
social position something was Seafort
will be successes type of stuff queen
bee six immediately is also interesting
he needs to take with the Queen with the
soup this is not great at all but maybe
I may be sufficient
yeah I'm really not I don't really
believe that this is the best possible
outcome it's it's a very good position
but I really thought there should be
some some type of very drastic
refutation I'm not sure that this is one
of those yeah but it's very nice that's
very nice I mean I control the center
and and have a very comfortable position
p6
okay 64 for heaven's sake night a seven
you know I can just take a seven with
the rope don't don't get
yeah now this this should be it should
be really good rotate you also
mm-hmm yeah but out soon how to win it's
very nice with the porn but should be a
check
their twenties time morning when sick
girl offered game drawn I don't know 20
seconds is really not much it's a shame
because I mean this is just just a win
for black probably yeah d4 i was i was
thinking about the move because it gives
me oops this excellent square this is
what i would have played but i wasn't
100% sure about this Gavin infecteds
it's this is very strong for black and
this I didn't see this is the problem he
cannot take here because often kept up
the capture with rupee one in this is
deadly really that's a kid he only has
got one nope one check one no useless
check and now can resign because this is
this is lost yeah well i didn't i didn't
really found find i spent so much time
you're looking for some some knockout
and I mean this was basically plenty
plenty enough to win and he should play
a bouquet 6 of course this is just just
giving it away and easily even yeah
there are many ways IAM c4 is good
trapping the bishop I mean okay it's a
winner all along but I just I was just
far too far too slow him okay thanks for
watching